[Music]
legend has it one day a new king will
come
[Music]
who will use the power of the Trident
tomate Atlantis back together one can
it's the exact spot that vocal giving my
first woman lesson no not even close you
have to forget all the teaching of the
surface world go deeper one covering
their Atlantean instincts he spent his
entire life change
planning to be the best
my parents made me what I am
I am the protector of the deep
in this Trident resides the power of
Atlantis in the romance it won't bring
destruction but in the hands of the true
air it would unite above and below the
time has come for Atlantis to rise again
Stockton about he proposed to me 2008 by
retrieving this early Elmo's not like
this one you don't the war is coming to
the surface whether you like it or not
I always knew you were special
you believe
you'd be the one to night out - whoa
he's always had a king
now I need something more
what could be greater than a king
here
[Music]
for me the most important thing is the
story that I'm telling whether it's a
scary set piece or a dramatic moment it
all comes down to the characters and if
you care about them Aquaman is very
powerful but what drives him comes from
a very human place historic resonated
with me instantly
it's not accepted here not really
accepted here and definite can identify
with that
I fell in love with the project and fell
in love with Mira
she's no damsel in distress she's miss
strong badass empowered superhero with
Aquaman a trick and also put up a fund
is designing a whole different world
that we've never seen before you're
pretty much just limited by your own
imagination it's just a whole lot of
magic on this project once they put all
these things together behind James his
vision blows my mind still the appeal of
it was to step into something else
you really are invigorated because of it
get experience all these amazing worlds
we haven't been under the ocean yet this
is our outer space I keep going back to
that inherent fascination that we have
with the ocean and if it turned on you
just the sheer vastness and the mystery
of it there's still a lot we don't know
I've always known that I want to do an
action movie I'll get to be a big kid on
a playground and cause trouble blow
things up your body is constantly
working with on judo jujitsu fight
choreography at four and a half months
stunt training six days a week
you feel pretty superhuman I get two
presents Aquaman
it's the whoa and this really badass and
cool way we have never seen this on
screen that's that's the truth get a
fall in love with the ideal what it's
like to have these powers be a kid and
that's fun for the family it's fun for
everyone we want to create something
interesting you don't want the standard
James one can't do the sander
any great superhero story should make
you feel that you've learned something
from these characters and you yourself
have the ability to do good and you
don't need a cape to be able to do that
my parents were from different worlds
and that was a product of the love that
never should have been could unite our
worlds one day a son of the land and a
son of the Seas
my mother always knew you were special
you are part of something deeper
you are the breech hand and see
your rightful place as king
[Music]
we're getting close now
well what's the what dying a thirst
there's no way Atlantis with this far
inland check this place out
[Music]
nothing of course it's not working it's
been sitting here collecting dust since
before the Sahara was a desert before
the Sahara was a desert let's see you do
your best thinking when you're not
thinking at all right now hold still hey
what are you doing we need water you're
the closest source
[Music]
showoff I could've just peed on it
in this Trident resides the power of
Atlantis
if you suit my power journey beyond the
edge of the world to the hidden sea
in the wrong hands
it won't bring destruction
but in the hands of the truly
it would unite all our kingdoms above
and below
what should we have written it down
first I memorized it didn't you
oh yeah what did you say
something-something trident the beast
has awakened the time has come
for Atlantis to rise again
the hell are you
Oh is awesome
the war is coming to the surface
you are not going to win this
ian's will die unless you help us
I'm no leader
I'm not king
[Music]
he's always had a king now I need
something more
what could be greater than again
[Music]
a hero my father was a lighthouse keeper
my mother was queen but life has a way
of bringing people together it unites
our foods Monday check it out
author it's talking to the fish
they made me what I am
listen to come aboard
[Music]
I've been looking for you your half
brother King arm is about to declare war
upon the surface world
the only way to stop this war is for you
to take your rightful place as king
trust me I know
do your best thinking when you're not
thinking at all that was the worst pep
talk ever
I want to strap in
my brother has come from the service
chatters meet for the throne I go on an
ass-whooping
I'm no leader
because I have no choice
can save my home and the people that I
love you think you're unworthy to lead
because you're two different worlds
and that is exactly why you are worthy
oh it's awesome
the war is coming to the surface
and I'm bringing the wrath of the seven
seas with me
what are you doing never parachute right
hoods you gotta love them
[Music]